and the golden globe goes too you want
to open it you want me to do it yeah
i have the nails yeah get after it you
got the globes too
um billy bob forden
fargo
but it's been a great year i learned
there's a whole other olson i found that
out this year
that's awesome where were they hiding
her huh
she's the best one come on
it's crazy this is amazing i can't
believe she was the mistake
it was uh and now
back to this [ __ ] that had a lot to say
about me the other day in the press
miley what's good
hey we're all in this industry
we all do interviews and we all know how
they manipulate [ __ ]
nikki congratulations
it was a great year for film uh women in
film catherine bigelow nominated tonight
i haven't really been following the
controversy over zero dark 30 but when
it comes to torture
i trust the lady who spent three years
married to james cameron
no taylor i'm really happy for you i'm
let you finish
but beyonce had one of the best videos
of all time
one of the best videos of all time
[Applause]
there are going to be people along the
way who will try to
undercut your success or take credit
for your accomplishments or your fame
you'll look around
and you will know that it was you and
the people who love you
who put you there and that will be the
greatest feeling in the world
a lot of people here that i love tonight
we got a little pump
we got little zan uh these are also the
reasons that your 12 year old cousin
wants a face too stop writing on your
goddamn face
stop writing on your face it's stupid
you're not going to get a job
if this [ __ ] don't work out stop it
our gymnastics team was so dominant that
kevin durant told me he wants to play
for them next year
[Applause]
the red is from that one time i didn't
win miss australia
and the black is from a funeral i just
went to
for the feature film cats
and i want to thank my haters too
because
because they be downloading my stuff so
they can hear it and saw crap about it
but it benefits me
what i want the world to know about
nicki minaj is when you hear nicki minaj
spit
nicki minaj wrote it
no no no shay um
no no no no no no shame
and the golden globe goes to
[Applause]
ben affleck argo
[Applause]
uh what was this award for i'm sorry
[Applause]
huh oh
oh viewers choice oh my god y'all thank
you
this year when you hear your name called
don't get up right away
give us a minute we don't want another
thing
our next presenters are two of the
funniest people in america
she stole the show on saturday night
live then went on to create write and
start her own show
30 rock he was a job in actor
career not going that well if i'm being
totally honest who
who got his big break when i cast him in
a remake
of a show that i created called the
office
he's now leaving that show and killing a
cash cow for both of us
please welcome the wonderful tina fey
and the ungrateful steve carrell
i love it never gets old
sam mendes mum scorsese todd phillips
quentin tarantino
i don't think i could do what they do
honestly
i just don't have the balls
[Applause]
and um shout out to donatella versace
for custom making this
outfit for me and shout out and shout
out to michael b
jordan because he's going to be taking
it off of me tonight
ricky gervais couldn't be here tonight
so instead we're going to give this to
our friend steve carell
[Applause]
look at his stupid face
couldn't actually win one of his own so
he stole someone else's
and secondly and even more important is
your whole career as a comedian
is about making fun of pretentious
high-minded self-congratulatory bs
events like this one
the whole feeling in this room of
reverence and honoring is the exact
opposite of everything
i have wanted my life to be about
i i really don't want to be up here i
want to be
in the back over there somewhere over
there saying something funny to somebody
about what a croc this whole thing is